robert spencer the united states
government is building a big beautiful
wall for about half a million dollars
using our taxpayer money and this new
wall which is going to be really
successful keeping out all kinds of bad
guys oh i'm sorry but it's not at the
southern border it's at joe biden's
beach house in delaware what do you make
of this do as i say not as i do
presidential policy
this is yet another example of how the
elites the political elites the media
elites the academic elites they hold
americans in contempt
and so they scold us and admonish us
that walls are racist and bigoted and we
can't possibly have a wall at the
southern border because it would be
racist and bigoted to and probably
islamophobic i don't know to keep these
people out and to try to protect
americans from the criminal elements and
the terrorists and so on who are
streaming into the country that would be
wrong
but then biden's handlers can turn
around and give the the fake president a
big beautiful wall as you say around his
beach house because they know really
that walls do work
and they know that the southern border
is in deep crisis but they don't care
because they don't have to pay the price
for it they can stay in their walled
beach houses in perfect comfort and it's
ordinary americans who have to live with
the consequences of their folly